thank you prime minister daria kallinik
um i had anti-corruption action center
from ukraine i passed the border a
couple of days ago
i'm from kiev most of my family uh most
of my team members are still in ukraine
in kiev
in lev
a woman
from
my team is now in bilateral
and she is there with his two kids
and
russian military is over there and she's
so much afraid that she will be shot
harkey the city where i was studying was
bombarded today fully the downtown
square
so you're talking about the stoicism of
ukrainian people but ukrainian women and
ukrainian children are in deep fear
because of bombs and missiles which are
going from the sky and ukrainian people
are desperately asking for the west to
protect our sky
we are asking for the no-fly zone we are
saying response that it will trigger
world war iii but what is the
alternative mr prime minister
to observe how our children are instead
of mis instead of
planes are protecting nato from the
missiles and bombs what's the
alternative for the no-fly zone
we have planes here we have air defense
system in poland in romania nato has
this air defense at least this air
defense could shield the western ukraine
so that these children with women could
come to the border it's impossible now
to cross the border there are 30
kilometers of lines imagine crossing the
border with a baby
or with two children i'm so glad that
samantha power is coming here to the
border from the polish side let her come
to the border from ukrainian side and
see that
britain guarantees our security under
budapest memorandum so you are coming to
poland you are not coming to kill prime
minister you are not coming to leave
because you are afraid
because nato is not willing to defend
because nato is afraid of the world war
iii but it is already started and these
are ukrainian children who are there
taking the hit
you're talking about more sanctions
prime minister but roman abramovich is
not sanctioned he's in london his
children are not in the bombardment his
children are there in london
putin's children are in netherlands
in germany
in mansions where all this mansion
seized i don't see that i see that my
family members
and my team members are saying that we
are crying we don't know where to rob
this is what is happening prime minister
well thank you thank you very much for
uh for your questions and and thank you
for for getting here today and i'm glad
that you you have been able to
to get here and uh look i just wanted to
say that i'm acutely conscious that
there is not enough that we can do
to as a uk government uh
to help in the way that you want and
i've got to be honest about that and
when you talk about the the no-fly zone
as i said to vladimir uh zalensky i i
think a couple of times
unfortunately the implication of of that
is that the
uh the uk and uh will be engaged in in
shooting down
uh russian
planes uh would be engaged in direct
combat uh with russia that's not
something uh that uh we can do that
we've uh that we've envisaged and i
think the consequences of that would be
uh
truly very very difficult to uh to
control what we can do
is all the things that we are uh doing
already and providing as much help and
support to the ukrainians as we as we
can as i said to you earlier on the uk
was the first uh
european country to offer military
assistance uh also
doing everything we can to tighten the
economic
news around the putin regime and we were
amongst the very first to put that
package together and
i have to to tell you i think that it
will work i think that vladimir putin's
venture is doomed uh to fail uh and i
think that uh it will be extremely
difficult for him to continue on the
path that he he is on but in the
meantime as you as you rightly say there
is going to be a period of of suffering
for the people of ukraine uh for which
putin and putin alone
is responsible he's taken a decision
that i think many people around the
world find absolutely
uh
inexplicable as well as inexcusable
and
it will take time i'm afraid for us to
to come through this period in all we
can do in the meantime is help people
like your your your crew and uh and
yours your uh your family to
to to get out to get to safety uh help
them uh with all the humanitarian
support that we can provide help them to
come to the uk
and uh we certainly will but i i cannot
pretend to you
that this is going to be something that
the uk can fix uh by military means and
i think it'll be wrong with me to do so
but what i will say is that i think that
this uh this whole a misadventure
by vladimir putin has raised questions
now
about uh the
security of of europe and what we do and
i think it was
entirely reasonable of vladimir zelensky
to uh to ask for instance for uh for eu
membership and i think that nato will
have to think
much more about uh some of the uh the
ways in which we think about uh about
european security in the future because
clearly uh if there if putin can attack
uh ukraine in a way that is unprovoked
uh a completely innocent country
then that has big implications uh for
the world and for the security of other
countries as well and that's why amongst
other things uh the uk is intensifying
our support uh not just for for poland
uh but for the baltic countries uh and
for all nato's uh eastern frontier and
if if putin thinks he's going to get uh
less nato he's going to push back on
nato as a result of this action he is
going to be gravely disappointed all
that's happening as a result of what he
is doing is it he is strengthening the
resolve not just of the ukrainians but
the resolve of the west
as well and
to get back to your you know your
fundamental question about why isn't the
west actually coming
and giving direct military support well
basically for the reasons uh that i've
given
but i i think you will also accept that
the crisis the the the the tragic crisis
of uh the ukrainians is moving
governments and peoples
think of the germans think of the eu
to do things uh that would hear the two
have been uh unthinkable and uh and and
that is a measure of the sympathy that
ukraine is currently uh evoking around
the world and i have no doubt that that
sympathy is going to be so strong and
going to grow but people will not rest
as i've said until this injustice is
reversed and putin is seen not just uh
fails but c is seen to have failed in
ukraine and i think the whole
international community will work
together to ensure
that you your family are able to live in
a sovereign and independent ukraine and
i'm sorry it's going to take time i'm
sorry it's going to be difficult and i'm
sorry for all the the tragedy and
suffering
that you've experienced but thank you
very very much for coming today and
asking your question i think i think
everybody here has really appreciated it
thank you
[Applause]